thank you very much
alright okay least we got a lot of show
I know it's it's so exciting to be here
that television show but let me let me
get to the news because a lot of people
watch this show to get the news so I
have to fill them in people are excited
because the 2016 presidential race
officially started this week we have our
first official candidate Ted Cruz Ted
Cruz people have Ted Cruz fever it's
kind of like that flu bug going around
but the [ __ ] comes out your mouth
notes head crews first in I gotta give
him points for not being coy right and
he kind of taken a page out of Obama's
playbook only a senator for two years
just like Obama was declare early just
like Obama did the big difference of
course is that Ted Cruz actually wasn't
born in America no Ted Ted Cruz who
present themselves the most all-american
guy ever born in Canada's fathers cubed
he's half Canadian and half Cuban he's
got the gravitas of Justin Bieber
combined with the people skills of
Scarface so we saw terrific candidate
and much
two years is a short time to be in
public service they asked him on Fox's
the other day what he's accomplished and
he said stopped bad things from
happening and that's his slogan ted cruz
america's diaphragm but interesting he
made his declaratory made his
declaration that he was going to run at
Liberty University you're familiar
that's Jerry Falwell --zz college wing
wing a college where they teach the
earth is 5,000 years old I'm not kidding
about that and it was mandatory for the
students to attend its speech of dead
crews and a lot of the kids were not
happy about it they were slyly revolting
and some of them had Rand Paul t-shirts
on you know one of them was reading a
science textbook under the Bible now
and when other fundamentalist news the
Republican governor of Indiana has
assigned a religious freedom bill which
allows businesses to refuse service to
gay customers that has got to hurt if
you're gay and someone tells you we
don't want your kind and Gary
but what I want to know is say you're a
restaurant how do you know who's gay I'm
a night when they did this with black
people it was easy to but whatever how
do they how do they do it with gay
people I read her at Bennigan's now if
you bring in a picture of you with the
vagina you get a free appetizer that's
not before I get sued by Bennigan's I
don't know if I'm sure Bennigan's are
very nice people and gays love them and
I just picked that Nick okay
it's where gays go Bennigan's they go to
Fire Island Palm Springs
Key West and Bennigan's as well okay so
now the sad story the week you saw this
the mystery of the Lufthansa Germanwings
plane that crashed in the Alps is not a
mystery anymore one of the pilots was
just depressed this is scary stuff
ondrea's Lubitz he was 28 is it friend
said he was bright but also somewhat
somber possibly sinister a little
offbeat uh what what doctors call German
today I think two hot used to worry
about the pilot being drunk now I'm like
well at least he's in a good mood
okay that's I'll drink with you captain
let me let me top that off for you sir
what would freak me out is Meister
wanted the meeting of pint of
haagen-dazs that would but but
apparently this this German pilot hid an
existing illness which he would have had
to do if he was on Obamacare I just want
to point that out
well oh one more thing about Ted Cruz he
the day after he declared he signed up
for Obamacare he filibustered it for 21
hours two years ago and now we signed up
because his wife is quitting her job he
got his health insurance through his
wife now she's quitting to help him on
the campaign trail so he doesn't have
health insurance so he signs up for
Obamacare he was asked about he said I
believe we should follow the text of
every law even laws I disagree with well
you know what Ted if you need some
medical marijuana
Oh
also some news on that front chris
Christie dead to me
chris Christie came out strongly against
legalizing marijuana said he said
legalize weed puts the lives of children
and citizens at risk as opposed to
obesity of course
chris Christie doesn't need weed he was
obviously born with the much yeah cuz
yeah cuz the drug war has been such a
giant success such a giant success we
found out that you see this the DEA
agents in South America were having sex
parties with the prostitutes paid for by
the drug cartels it's not cool the
Justice Department said they were
outraged this was going on and the
Secret Service said they were outraged
they weren't invited
you